you've done all this research and
competitive analysis so now what well
use it you can get sharp on your
original idea or alter the idea based on
what you learned from user research and
other early idea validation we have four
activities that can help you get more
clarity on your idea the first is a
Twitter description how would you
announce your product in 140 characters
or less this activity helps you get
laser focus on the keys or value and
your product market fit the second is
you could write a future press release
how would your product first appear in
the news you can use this structure to
focus yourself and your team the
structure ensures that you capture your
future vision the third is a one-page
executive summary
this is the shortest in clearest way to
define your product and finally the
fourth is an experience strategy
template this template is appropriate
for defining new product categories and
the instructor notes you'll find
templates for each of these activities
take a minute to read over them and
think about which one would help you get
more clarity on your idea